I haven't followed the NBA in a long
time you know I gave up on the NBA when
they went full BLM and that's also when
I gave up on LeBron James people maybe
we'll be surprised by this but I was
actually a big LeBron James fan for a
long time uh I just as an athlete I was
a big fan of his
to my shame I was up until about three
years ago uh when he really went full
BLM so anyway I don't watch anymore but
this one moment jumped out at me as it's
gone viral the um the playoffs have
started I guess and the Milwaukee Bucks
were just eliminated and their star
player Giannis with the last name I
won't even attempt was asked about
whether the season was a failure because
they got eliminated from the playoffs
and uh and this is one of the very rare
moments when an athlete in a post-game
press conference says something
worthwhile and interesting but uh here
it is let's watch
do you view this season as a failure
oh my God
okay because I'm not that up
you asked me the same question last year
Eric okay uh do you get do you get the
promotion every year
on your job no right so every year you
work is a failure yes or no no every
every year you work you work towards
something two years ago Michael Jordan
played 15 years won six Championship the
other nine years was a failure that's
what you're telling me you know there's
good days bad days some days some days
you are able to uh be successful so this
you're not some days it's your turn so
this is not your turn and that's what
sport is about you don't always win
that's good stuff I like that because
it's a very it's a dad speech that is uh
and that's what I do it's like my entire
show with everything going on in the
world sometimes you just need a break
from it all choose to strengthen your
faith despite this broken world through
prayer meditation and fasting today
hello helps me maintain a daily prayer
routine gives me a break from the
craziness around me if you need a break
you need hallow the number one Christian
Prayer app in the U.S download the app
for free at hollow.com Matt Walsh you
can set prayer reminders track your
progress all along the way not sure
where to start we'll check out father
Mike schmitz's Bible in a year podcast
available on the Hello app for brief
daily Bible readings and Reflections or
you can pray alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim
Caviezel and even some world-class
athletes with how low you can customize
a personal prayer plan that works for
you listen anywhere you are with a
downloadable offline sessions as well
there's no better time to stay rooted in
your faith and values get an exclusive
three-month free trial at hello.com Matt
Walsh that's hello.com Matt Walsh that
is I can imagine I don't know if he's a
father or not but he'll he'll make a
very good father if he's not because
that's uh that's like the speed it's not
like a father talking to his son just
lost you know uh coming home from from
Little League and he's given the speech
to him and I think it's very good and
also it's as I said it rare to hear
something eloquent and interesting from
an athlete in a post-game press usually
all they do is Mumble cliches they were
out playing with all this energy and
then for some reason they get in front
of cameras they can barely speak and
it's then it's just yeah you know we
fought hard out there and the other team
fought hard and
um
take my hat off to him tip my cap gotta
tip my cap just take my hat off to him
take my hat off to the other guys really
taking my hat off for some reason every
athlete in every major sport has glommed
on to this one cliche about taking their
hat off I'm not really sure it's it's
funny it's a funny one too because it
Harkens back to Victorian era chivalry
where men tip their top hats when a lady
walks by it is what we're supposed to
imagine these seven foot lumbering dudes
are doing but anyway
um
I think it's uh it's an important lesson
and it's really what we were what we
were talking about earlier in the week
about the uh the rocket explosion for
SpaceX that if you're pursuing a goal
and you don't achieve it
but you learn from the failure and you
get better and you keep up the pursuit
then it's not a failure the only true
failure is the failure to try at all and
I know that that sounds like a cliche
too but and maybe it is but it's true
um there are people out there
who we could unfortunately describe as
failures there are a lot of people out
there these days
sadly who we could say are failures
these are failures of human beings
but we only can label them failures
because they didn't
try to do anything they didn't try
anything they didn't pursue anything
they didn't have any goals that they
went out and chased
um they didn't do that they didn't do
anything because they were afraid and
because it takes too much effort and um
and they took the path of least
resistance and that's a failure that's a
failure of a person so that's a person
who's failing
failing every day to try
but if you're pursuing your goals even
if you don't reach them every single
time not a failure overall
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]